[Música]
bienvenidos al enlace andino desde
bogotá colombia en esta ocasión
hablaremos sobre cómo se llegó a un
acuerdo de paz entre el gobierno
colombiano y la antigua guerrilla farc y
cómo ha sido el proceso en los últimos
cinco años que han pasado abordaremos el
origen de este grupo insurgente y lo que
llevó al gobierno de colombia a hacer la
paz con este grupo y finalmente daremos
un vistazo a los puntos del acuerdo y
por qué algunos de ellos no se han
cumplido hasta ahora
[Música]
una de las características del conflicto
armado en colombia ha sido la pluralidad
de actores que lo han alimentado y
transformado en el caso de las fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de colombia farc
lo que ellos querían era acabar con las
desigualdades sociales y económicas así
como alcanzar una participación política
en el país pero entonces su estrategia
consistió en una lucha armada que desde
1964 y hasta 2016 provocó la muerte de
miles de personas
después de décadas de violencia y varios
intentos fallidos de diálogos entre el
gobierno y las farc en 2011 se retomaron
las discusiones bajo el gobierno del
presidente juan manuel santos noruega y
cuba sirvieron como países garantes y
luego de cuatro años de discusiones de
un plebiscito en el que los colombianos
no apoyaron la iniciativa y de una
renegociación de lo pactado finalmente
se firmó un acuerdo en una ceremonia el
26 de septiembre de 2016 en la ciudad de
cartagena y otra final en bogotá el 24
de noviembre de ese mismo año
en este tratado de las farc dejaron las
armas se les dio la oportunidad de
reiniciar su vida en la sociedad civil y
también de tener una participación
política en el congreso vamos a ver
cuáles fueron los puntos planteados en
este documento en el acuerdo se propuso
una reforma rural integral para apoyar y
transformar el campo colombiano una
participación política de los ex
combatientes y la transformación de las
farc en el partido común es el fin de 52
años de conflicto con el cese bilateral
de las hostilidades en ambos bandos
además se inició el programa nacional
integral de sustitución de cultivos
ilícitos se estableció una jurisdicción
especial para la paz una comisión de la
verdad y una unidad de búsqueda de
personas dadas por desaparecidas y
finalmente se concertó la implementación
verificación y refrendación del acuerdo
final es decir garantizar que si se está
cumpliendo
estamos al frente del teatro colon y fue
justamente en este lugar donde se firmó
el acuerdo de paz el 24 de noviembre de
2016 y estoy en compañía de maría
victoria llorente directora ejecutiva de
la fundación ideas para la paz cómo está
maría victoria muy bien gracias andrea
está muy contenta de estar aquí con
ustedes bueno maría victoria este
acuerdo de trabajo mucha esperanza para
los colombianos pero también mucha
desilusión vemos que siguen las masacres
que todavía hay desplazamiento forzado y
que incluso hay asesinatos de personas
como los líderes sociales y aquellos que
firmaron el acuerdo en 2016 para
victoria que ha fallado en este acuerdo
de paz pues andrea yo en realidad no
creo que haya fallado el acuerdo de paz
en sí mismo el acuerdo de paz es un
propósito grande son varios propósitos
es una es un acuerdo para que terminemos
el conflicto y construyamos paz en el
largo plazo en colombia hablar de que ha
fallado el acuerdo
digamos muy desesperanzador estamos
apenas a 5 años bueno y cuáles han sido
los grandes desafíos que han complicado
la implementación de este acuerdo pero
yo creo que hay como tres grandes
desafíos uno que es muy claro y que es
el que estamos viviendo y están viviendo
muchas comunidades en colombia en este
momento y es el desafío y la seguridad
realmente no hemos logrado
resolver el tema de cómo se protege a
las comunidades a las poblaciones en
esas zonas
digamos que siguen siendo afectadas por
diferentes conflictos que se están
presentando con grupos armados ilegales
en esos territorios por otro lado en la
segunda que que ver con las capacidades
del estado o sea que realmente
implementar asuntos como por ejemplo la
reforma rural integral pues son temas de
largo plazo por eso el acuerdo incluso
puso una temporalidad de 15 años que yo
creo que incluso ese es poco en términos
de tiempo porque sé
e ir instalando capacidades para que eso
se pueda se pueda lograr el acuerdo pues
sabemos que estuvo ha estado envuelto en
medio de una gran polarización ha sido
digamos como el corazón de la
polarización política y de la élite
política en colombia en los últimos años
y eso verdaderamente genera y dificulta
mucho que nos pongamos de acuerdo
sabemos que el gobierno del presidente
eduque es parte de este sector que no
estuvo completamente de acuerdo con lo
pactado y que incluso han tratado de
modificar el acuerdo original cree usted
que existe el riesgo de que se pierda la
esencia de lo pactado no yo yo la verdad
creo que humano depende primero de que
es pensamos que es la esencia de lo
pactado no porque pues uno puede decir
que la esencia no pactado es que ese
acuerdo se implemente de manera integral
digamos todos los puntos del acuerdo
tienen que avanzarse en ellos de manera
integral y yo creo que en ese sentido
pues este gobierno se ha tenido
dificultades de verdaderamente hacer es
hacer digamos lograr eso
por otro lado si uno entiende que la
esencia del acuerdo es lograr que en
colombia no haya más violencia asociada
con la actividad política yo creo que en
ese sentido digamos si bien no hemos
logrado impedir que sigan asesinando a
líderes y demás de todas maneras si hay
un gran acuerdo nacional sí creo que hay
un acuerdo nacional alrededor de que eso
no va más
maria victòria muchísimas gracias por
haber estado aquí con nosotros andreas
gracias por haberme invitado bueno y
esto fue enlace andino desde bogotá a
ustedes los invito a que sigan con
nosotros en france24 punto com hasta la
próxima
[Música]